More than ten years after going off the air,
Chappelle's Show is still eminently watchable,
quotable, and hilarious.
But why did Dave Chappelle resonate in the
first place?
And why, after all these years, do we still
need him more than ever?
High And Low
Has anybody so enthusiastic about diarrhea
humor ever been called a "genius" as often
as Dave Chappelle?
In a single stand-up set, he can go from mudbutt
into dangerous neighborhoods, highlight the
injustice of our legal system, incisively
criticize the president, and then leave the
planet with three cloned triplets, a space
alien, and the cure for AIDS.
You almost don't realize you're learning something.
He Shows His Flaws
The hardest part of being relatable is letting
yourself be a little vulnerable.
Chappelle is a master of reminding us that
he's just another guy—wildly successful,
but just as insecure as anybody else.
And he's not afraid to admit when he's made
a mistake, or at least a bad joke.
The infamous Wayne Brady incident is a perfect
example, with a joke about Brady's supposed
whiteness going too far.
“White people love Wayne Brady because he
makes Bryant Gumbel look like Malcom X.”
Chappelle brought Brady on the show as an
apology.
The resulting sketch about how Brady was too
street even for Chappelle became an instant
classic.
And all because Chappelle was open enough
to realize and apologize for his mistake.
Hip-Hop Ambassador
The show's relationship with music brought
some of the all-time greats into homes of
millions of Americans.
But it's the movie Dave Chappelle's Block
Party that really proves his hip-hop and soul
bona fides.
The movie is a behind-the-scenes look at the
days leading up to a free block party Dave
threw on the streets of New York.
Its inclusiveness is heartwarming, and joy
radiates from every frame.
“Next thing we know we see Dave Chappelle.
“
“Ha Ha Ha…
Do you like rap music?
WIll y’all come to my block party in New
York?
It’s in Brooklyn on Saturday”
“Ohhh”
It's the rare concert film that feels truly
special, as the show goes on in the pouring
rain in front of an audience full of people
who otherwise might not be able to afford
the concert's fantastic lineup.
Oh, and there's some jokes, too.
Master Of The Craft
Dave famously got his start in stand-up at
a young age, climbing onstage at age 14 and
just riffing on whatever.
Sure, he has constructed jokes, but he's comfortable
fitting them in between bits of stream-of-consciousness
comedy and audience interaction.
Sometimes it backfires, and his comedy turns
downright antagonistic.
But even when it's not funny, there's something
thrilling about seeing a master in the process
of creating.
Frank And Inclusive On Race
If there's one thing about Chappelle's comedy
that has true importance, it's the frank way
in which he talks about race, using humor
to bridge the gaps between people.
Take, for example, the classic sketch "I Know
Black People," in which Chappelle irreverently
explores the inherent humor in our differences
by testing random people on their knowledge
of black culture.
It's these little observations, surface-funny
but deeply felt, that truly do a service to
society at large.
We're different, but we're not that different,
and none of us are too good to be the butt
of a great joke.
It's an approach that brings us closer, and
it's why—even all these years after he edged
out of the spotlight—we're still waiting
for Dave Chappelle.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what
your favorite Dave Chappelle sketch is…